I said I'm adequate love avocado as many
of you know the Quran put forth a
challenge to bring something like it
however instead of the disbelievers
taking part of that challenge they waged
war against the Muslims now keep in mind
this was a society that thrived on these
challenges and always never back down
from such challenges and they took part
in these poetry battles of you may
however instead of taking part and the
challenge you had a lot of these major
poets like a sunburn Thabit cabin Malik
Abdullah Baraka and even levied himself
accepting Islam instead now flash
forward a thousand four hundred years
later and you have some missile Keane
who are taking up the or on challenge
and thinking that they've actually
succeeded now one of these one of these
missile keen attempted to take a book or
on a challenge and he produced a Sulha
which he called [ __ ] off and I'm going
to make an example out of this surah and
demonstrate to you how bad these
imitations or on imitations really are
not only that but I'm going to be using
this surah to demonstrate how eloquent
the Quran actually is alright so first a
quick background this video was
reapplied a few times on YouTube and has
over eighty thousand views the person
that produced these verses has a degree
in classical Arabic and some history the
surah was called off which is wordplay
on off now just a quick disclaimer I
don't believe that this piece deserves
to even be critiqued but I'm just doing
this to show you how those who attempt
or on challenged camps really escape the
eloquence of the Quran which they admit
without even realizing you're gonna see
what I mean in a bit okay so I'm
splitting my criticism into two parts
the first part is gonna be about
the ridiculous of meanings and the
second part I'm going to be focusing on
the examples of eloquence they're ripped
off from the blonde was an opponent oh
oh
[Music]
coming for me at a national collusion
notice here the author speaks of the
signs of the Lord these signs include
God's creation of chickens God boiling
eggs God sending thunder and lightning
and God making air fresh now first of
all boiling an egg is not a sign of God
anyone can boil an egg secondly he says
the thunder is sent now Thunder isn't
sent thunder is the cause of lightning
lightning can be sent and thunder is not
sent in other words this is just a word
choice
let's carry on formation ha
okay so this is ridiculous as it makes
no sense you don't hang someone then
choke them you do one or the other
what's the point of choking someone who
has already been hanged it's stupid
woman number thirteen notice the
emphasis here he knocks the door a
knocking why what is so special about
knocking this door why is there an
emphasis here now the only reason I can
think of this person used this word a
knocking at the end is because his
person was thinking to themselves hmm I
need to let through the ends with a LOF
para otra ho
okay so knock he knocked a knocking yes
and we do that you sacrifice the meaning
tax that's not eloquent consumer me but
was a movie and began here I swear by
the braying of the ass how is this
eloquent just because it rhymes and I
mean look look at how it lines up to the
next verse so a creator of the brave the
donkey how is it supposed to be eloquent
so rule number one if it's stupid it's
not eloquent it doesn't matter if you
write me to sing it or beatbox it it's
garbage
[Music]
and what's on our the who is skimming so
there is an issue here why does it say
dancing girls with no veil because
dancing girls with no veil as a given of
course they aren't wearing veils what is
the point of enticing someone with a
dancer with no veil so I'll tell you why
this was said it was said because they
wanted to force a rhyme at the end of
the verse so they ended the verse with
the word veil came on to fit in with
rivers and hard now by doing this you
sabotage the meaning of the verse for
the sake of the rhyme okay so let's just
move on to the good stuff alright so
here I'm going to provide examples of
how the author of these verses submits
to the Platonic challenge without
realizing here's an example
[Music]
so verse 21 here is a direct report from
Quran Allah subhana Allah uses these
exact words in 225 5 1:19 mine 89 and 85
11 now why would someone who's trying to
meet the charge before on directly rip
off a verse that's been repeated so many
times in the Quran is it perhaps because
they didn't know how to express it
better maybe also notice verse 20 the
English says they are the best this is a
precise translation the word in the home
translates to they are the word home
translates to they are as well a better
translation of this is they themselves
are the best this usage is a ripoff from
verses like to 12 where Allah sprang to
Allah speaks of the hypocrites they the
hypocrites say we are peacemakers now
surely they themselves are the
mischief-makers but they do not perceive
as you can see the author is trying to
imitate the quran style but fails badly
this structure which focuses on emphasis
is used to firm a claim or a view that
contradicts the original claim in this
case it's only when the hypocrites say
we are peacemakers that Allah uses the
structure of a themselves or
mischief-makers so the author of these
verses is just using these words because
they sound cool but in reality this
person has no idea but the way they're
supposed to be used
anyhow here's another example
okay mama
notice the term la which suggests
negation is not used in English this is
because the term la here is used as an
affirmation in other words it does say I
swear so this is linguistically correct
even though it seems to say I do not
swear so where did the author get this
idea from that's right he learned this
form of emphasis from the Quran in 56 75
69 3870 40 80 115 and 84 16
let me explain one more time so the
author of these verses is so influenced
by the Quran they're submitting to the
elements of the plan without even
realizing they cannot escape
plagiarizing it and they cannot escape
using the Aaronic sentence structures
now producing something like it doesn't
mean rip it off it doesn't mean copy the
verses and just change one word here and
one word there and then use something
like it no the challenge is to produce
something on the same level of eloquence
now keep in mind that these examples
I've mentioned examples like in the home
home and Fela oxen these are introduced
by the Quran Arabs don't speak like this
the person who has used these words
never spoke like this in their lives
however when they're trying to be
eloquent they can't escape using Aaronic
structure when the author of these
verses attempts to meet the blonic
challenge while failing to express
themselves without using exclusive or an
extractor this shows that they have
failed the challenge and testifies to
the eloquence of Quran in other words
they're submitting to the Quran without
even realizing when I'm not in a banana
me if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to this channel and of course
as always you got any questions you can
contact me via my Twitter but sit down I
take on love when it comes to boy
[Music]
don't fear we be what they're all sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that theory